le président de l'université des
antilles et sur ce plateau saint-jean
qui bonsoir bonsoir les mots des
responsables de la faculté du pôle
martinique mais aussi des élèves sont
durs on entend parler de tragédie de
dérive de la présidence guadeloupe et à
la martinique sera t-elle dépouillé
comme on vient d'entendre je trouve que
c'est grave je lisais ses mots devant
une population qui n'est pas très
renseigné dire qu'il ya une tragédie non
il y à des textes de loi il ya une
répartition des moyens qui sont fixées
par la loi
il ya des critères de répartition que
nous appliquons il s'agit pas de
dépouiller un pôle pour un autre
policier d'harmoniser parce que jusqu'à
maintenant la configuration ne répond
pas aux critères de loin quand les
lister les antilles a été mise en place
elle a été mise en place avec des lois
qui ont été votées maintenant il faut
mettre en place ces lois quand j'ai pris
l'université les statuts venait tout
juste d'être votée rien n'avait été fait
encore pour mettre en place cet univers
est donc moi j'ai j'ai pris les textes
et j'ai commencé à mettre en place les
textes qui sont cultes et voter tous nos
critères de répartition les applications
très simple il ya le nombre d'étudiants
le type d'étudiant
le type d'études étudier cela veut dire
les études suivies par ses études ses
étudiants ceux qui sont en lettres ont
un budget inférieur par rapport à ceux
qui sont dans les disciplines
scientifiques au les disciplines
scientifiques soit en guadeloupe et 10
militaires soit en martinique
le nombre d'étudiants est supérieur en
gold 2000 étudiants de plus en moyenne
par rapport à la martinique sans compter
la recherche
il est même pas pris en considération la
recherche s'il fallait prendre cet
élément-là du pool et le budget diminuer
pour la martinique sans compter aussi
les surfaces nous avons pratiquement le
double du sud des shows fasse pas pour
la martinique enfin la voile opaque
pratiquement le double alors nous la
martinique les élus les membres du
conseil d'administration martiniquais
conteste contre la répartition de la
masse salariale
la plus pour la guadeloupe - ce pour la
martinique également un budget c'est 7
millions d'euros sur dix ans c'est ce
sont ces postes vacants qui justifie ce
transfert de 7 millions
il faut savoir que quand l'université de
la guyane a été créé il y a eu des
enseignants et enseignants-chercheurs
qui confère des droits d'option qui sont
venus en majorité en martinique plus de
vingt enseignants enseignants-chercheurs
son arrivée en martinique en guadeloupe
la libération était neutre il y avait
environ cinq arrivées et 5 pas un parti
le placier neutre ces vingt enseignants
sont venus s'ajouter aux enseignants
existant en martinique
donc ce qui veut dire que quand on fait
le le ratio enseignants chercheurs et
étudiants
forcément il ya beaucoup plus
d'enseignants chercheurs et enseignants
martin parr pour leur dos et certains
parlent de discrimination parce qu'en
réalité quand on est des étudiants de la
même université ne profite pas des mêmes
avantages
c'est une discrimination alors les
pourparlers des postes vacants
il ya effectivement des postes vacants
beaucoup de bosses bac en martinique et
sur ses six essieux ses poses vacants
qu'on va faire le montage
cela veut dire que des gens ne se
rendent compte de rien du tout
ces postes ne sont pas utilisés et on ne
veut pas faire on va pas prendre ces
pauses lacan brutalement on va prendre
un pourcentage 40% et on va laisser dans
durant les années sigean qui va-t-on
vers la scission des deux pôles c'est
pas le prix le projet du président de
président est nommé et voté par est élu
pour faire fonctionner une université
l'université des antilles maintenant il
est très clair seul cela fait deux ans
que j'essaie de d'harmoniser que
j'essaie de faire fonctionner cette
université on ne peut plus avancer de
cette manière si on n'applique pas la
loi on est hors la loi et moi je suis là
pour faire appliquer la loi
si certains ne veulent pas qu'on
applique la loi qu'ils demandent leur
université et le président ce ne sera
pas contre
et si cela devait arriver quelles
seraient les conséquences
les conséquences sont très graves on est
2 bat deux départements petit déjà et
qui deux départements qui vieillit
ce qui veut dire que le nombre
d'étudiants ne va pas évoluer votre aval
le nom va même diminué qui veut dire que
l'on a deux gros de gros lycée tout
simplement avoir des enseignants
chercheurs les enseignants chercheurs ne
viendront peut-être pas chez nous parce
qu'ils vont chercher vos désirs on où on
leur propose des postes intéressants où
il ya des mastères gars de la recherche
mais si on doit se scinder ben c'est
grave
bien évidemment ceux qui sont ceux qui
en plus d'étudiants plus de chez
recherches pourront peut-être s'en
sortir mais les autres rôles du mal
merci c'est gentil d'être venu ce soir
sur ce plateau
merci